Oh shark NATO now you may be wondering
Chris why in the world are you reviewing
this movie well if you follow me on
Twitter or like my Facebook page you
would have seen me post a status and a
tweet saying that sharknado is going to
be in theaters for one night this
weekend in Regal Cinemas would you like
me to review it the response was
overwhelmingly yes so here I am talking
about sharknado because this is what I
do
sharknado is actually pretty
self-explanatory believe it or not a
hurricane starts up on the coast of
California which eventually turns into a
tornado and there's sharks in it just
there's flying around and flying
everywhere on land without water and
they're breathing and everything because
that's what sharks do they breathe on
land now look don't get me wrong the
movies called sharknado the tagline is
enough set it stars terror read this is
obviously a bad movie and sci-fi channel
knows it because this was originally a
made-for-television movie sci-fi channel
makes these horrible horrible horrible
made-for-tv scary movies but it's got
this cult following kind of cuz the
title I think I think the title really
kind of got everyone going like wow I
have to watch that immediately and it
eventually got a one day release in
theaters so it officially is a movie
that came out in theaters this year and
Here I am reviewing it this is a
terrible movie obviously Wow
but you guys knew that I mean it's
called sharknado I'm not telling
anything you don't know
but what really actually shocked me was
how poorly constructed literally
everything is the acting is
bottom-of-the-barrel
awful the special effects are in no way
special they look like a PlayStation 2
game to be honest you got the sharks
flying everywhere chomping at things and
like I said they're on land there
they're flapping around on land and
eating people it's not like they're in
the water somehow they're on land and
the editing of this film is just
appalling like you have random split
second shots of things just sort of
blurring by the screen maybe a person
runs by real quick you don't know where
when what happened a helicopter will be
crash landing in the next shot all of a
sudden it's landed it's fine it's on
land it's nothing never idle oh boy see
the thing about sharknado is it's
definitely trying to be so bad that it's
good is it so bad that's good some
people will feel that way if you have
the right group of people watching this
movie for sitting down with your friends
maybe a little bit tipsy I don't know if
you're just excited to watch a stupid
movie it's one thing if you're me who
watch this by myself because I said I
would it was a pretty torturous
experience direction in this movie is
non-existent it all looks like some
handheld thing that some way I said hey
okay do that one take good we're done
every single shot is half-assed every
line is half-assed the special effects
or half-assed everything's half-assed
about this movie Jon heard whatever
happened to him he was the dad and home
alone yet a few hits in the 90s and then
all of a sudden he's in sharknado
playing a drunk old guy I don't know
what happened here but here he is in
sharknado for your entertainment not
really see I don't really want to rip
this movie a new one cuz you guys know
what's gonna be bad and I'm telling you
it's bad but it's bad and you knew that
but it really is awful like there isn't
anything about the movie that that's
well done it's just you go to sharknado
and you're gonna laugh at the fact that
it's literally a tornado filled with
sharks the thing is going around and
their idea of how to stop the tornado is
to go up in a helicopter fly right next
to the tornado and drop bombs into the
tornado because the bombs will then
explode the tornado kill all the sharks
in the tornado and then everyone will be
okay somehow I don't really know what
the logic isn't that but this is a film
where sharks breathe on land so you know
there really isn't any logic at all I
think there really honestly annoy me
about this movie was actually terror
read see a lot of the actors in the
movie you can tell they're not taking it
seriously like you they know it's awful
but she is like she's really trying and
I guess maybe I give you her credit for
that but don't try to be an oscar-worthy
actress when you're in sharknado why I'm
not gonna spoil it for you in case you
decided to see the movie but the ending
is pretty incredible like when it
happened I literally sat in my seat or
like you gotta be kidding me they're
gonna do that oh they did it and then
did that and then oh so that's how it's
gonna be this movie really is terrible
it's I kind of hate it there's also a
lot of obvious lines that are copying
off of jaws like there's a scene where
the girl is talking about this story
where sharks killed all of her friends
and she's like the Sharks took the rest
I was like really
the Sharks took the rest and that was
the Indianapolis so I'm Quinta dad the
doll's eyes black eyes and those eyes
they roll over white and onion terrible
high-pitched screaming I'll never put on
a life jacket again and the same
character laters like we're gonna need a
bigger chopper I was like you've got to
be sharknado is awful but you knew that
you know I'm not telling anything you
don't know is it funny at times it is
there's some awesome parts where sharks
just follow on people from the sky I
mean how many times are you gonna see
that in the movie but for the most part
I really don't think you have to see
this one maybe if you are with like a
group of friends on a Friday night and
you got nothing to do and you guys got
some popcorn you got some candy you got
some soda and you guys are going to get
together and watch this movie on
television and just laugh your butts off
and in between breaks you're going to be
doing something else you're not really
going to be paying attention to it that
is where sharknado belongs right there
anywhere else
no I'm gonna give sharknado and F it's a
terrible movie it's not good at all but
like I said I mean it's called sharknado
so you knew that already thanks as
always for watching guys and if you
liked this you can click right here and
get stuck my nice
Oh